this year please was so involved it's
hard to believe that it all happened in
a single year I look back at 2018 then I
kind of try to catalogue all the
different things that happened in this
year and I cannot understand how this
all happened this year I don't believe
that I was in Europe at the beginning of
this year but I was so this year was
very involved I'm not sure even where to
begin but I thought I'd do or a little
recap of everything that happened this
year and just go from there and then
talk about what's gonna happen in the
next year cuz I got big plans for this
next year I got big plans that I'm gonna
be doing I just don't know how to do it
yet I do know how to do it that's a lie
I've been puttin it plans in motion
since before even the year started it's
it's not that I don't know what I'm
doing I do know what I'm doing I know
what I'm doing so I made a mistake I
made another mistake and then I went on
tour and I went on tour in America and
in Europe Europe was great then we fell
in love with me fell in love I sold a
rock sort of rock xx xx and then I went
to one video a day from two videos a day
probably the biggest change in my
channel just in how I approach content
has been that change but it's also been
the best it's not an excuse to get lazy
but it is an excuse to do other stuff
cuz it all honesty I think it turned out
way for the best
that's not words I think it turned out
for the best because I was able to do
what I wanted to do when I wanted to do
it and that was good
that's not a good reasoning I was able
to put more work into every single video
by creating like the three videos three
games in a video videos three video
video in their video videos you ever
have that many videos in a video no not
that many videos and then I made a
promise I'm gonna be going to one video
a day and then I broke that promise but
that was obvious because we sold oh I
got naked
I got real naked I got super naked for a
calendar whose bargain anyway I got
naked which was cool and then I made a
promise and then I broke that promise
because I had to sign all the calendars
for me getting naked
I signed 38,000 calendars which was
something bad I ate a ghost pepper and
then I didn't eat a ghost pepper because
I was bad for me and probably it was bad
and then I went into exile I forgot
about that I went into exile this year
that was this year I got hat I was next
oh but chug an entire glass of pepper
juice I was in exile and then I came out
of Exile abroad then I came out of exile
from tribe Trump Trump if I came out of
exile triumphantly and that was all that
was all in the beginning of this year
that wasn't even remotely close to
that's not even remotely close to yab
all these basics also happened this year
did you believe that all these basics
was a thing this year then I leaked my
phone number and you broke that
immediately so thank you for breaking
that cuz you break everything this year
I made a promise and those Millford was
another one then there was Wilford lulu
mother loving mother loving the wharfs -
that came out in August that was more
recent that was definitely this year
also extremely happy with how that went
and then I made this sweeping promise
that there was gonna be more of those
projects coming at you real soon and
that wasn't that long ago and that the
the next project has been in the works
for a while but it's taking longer and
there's been delays and there's been
legitimate reasons for the delays but
I'll explain that after it comes out a
lot of mystery stuff a lot of questions
I just want to make better cover but
it's gonna come out soon sometime this
year I don't know when it does though
it's gonna blow your mind
right and then I went to Korea and Korea
was great honestly truly Korea was great
because I got to see my family I got to
make a lot of memories I got to live
life I get to see like all these people
that have never been in
able to interact with I made some videos
I got murdered by a small child and then
when I came home I launched whoa cloak
look at my nib woke I launched cloak
with Jack and while also pull dancing
those nice and then then it's been a
little quiet a little quiet leading up
to Oh No Australia hasn't been quiet at
all
good God then we went to Australia I
petted a roo and I almost got murdered
by a roof but that's okay yeah when I
came back there was a hole I had to do
my part I'd do my part for big Papa
pewds
way up I miss you
[Music]
yes if that happened and then I prepared
for Christmas vacation then the pick
charity stream at the end of the year
which had so many technical problems but
it's okay that's alright it was very fun
and I'm really happy that we did it and
then I came home and that is a brief
summary of everything that happened this
year now pay attention listen close
you're not listening you're off doing
homework hey shut up look at me
you weren't even talking shut up look at
me now yes you look alright this next
year I could start this off by making a
bunch of grand sweeping statements about
how I've got so many resolutions to do
this year and how I'm gonna make a big
change and everything's gonna be grand
and great so that's exactly what I'm
gonna do because that's exactly how this
is gonna go down I don't even know if
slapping this table causes a ruckus
that's what I'm gonna do this is gonna
be shut up don't laugh at me I've been
all seriousness last year was incredible
it really was there was so much that
happened this past year that it's hard
to believe that it was all in one year
and I've come so far in terms of you
know personal growth ability to do other
stuff like professional projects
whatever you want to call it like a
seeker has been a big big year for me
like 2017 kind of like skated by and I
wasn't really paying attention but man
2018 was I don't know 2018 was insane
just with the amount of stuff so what I
want to do in this next year is I want
to get back to my roots and what that
means is I've been doing a lot of other
projects that have been outside of
YouTube and that have existed outside of
the sphere of YouTube's influence and
like I've been on tour I've been
launching all these like businesses and
I've been doing all these big projects
and I've been having fancy meetings with
fancy people and all of it's just like
it's just such a drain because it
distracts from what I really want to do
which is make videos for you guys like
that's all I've ever wanted to do and
the idea that I've gotten away from that
is what really bothers me
so this year is actually going to be the
year that I actually focus and try again
at YouTube because I think we can all
agree that
thing I have not been doing this year is
trying and it's not that I've been not
working hard it's not that I've been
lazy something you may disagree with
that but it's not that I've been lazier
not working hard you said I've been
working hard in the areas that haven't
really made me feel confident in what
I'm doing you know what I mean in the
areas that like aren't creatively
fulfilling aren't weird like aren't
funny aren't fun to do aren't engaging
you know they're not interesting
so in this year like I've got a lot of
plans and ambitions and new year's
resolutions to do a bunch of stuff for
self-improvement like I always do but at
the end of the day I want to just be
able to make videos again and I want to
be able to focus on that first and
foremost to give you guys cool content
and make me feel like I'm actually doing
something worthwhile while I still have
the chance to do it so that's what I'm
gonna do and there's no concrete plans
to that except for these exact concrete
plans that I'm about to outline right
now I want to do
markiplier makes Monday's markiplier
tries Tuesdays scary game Wednesday's
awesome game Thursday's markiplier
reacts 5 multiplayer Saturday he's
surprised Sundays I don't know [ __ ] I
don't know whatever III honestly have no
idea that's like a rough idea though so
I have absolutely an idea of what I want
to do so we'll see if it can actually be
done but if not then it won't be any
different and you won't be surprised but
hey there's always the possibility that
I will do it except for the fact that
I'm delay shut up
except for the fact that I am in
Cincinnati right now and I have to get
back to Los Angeles and then I have to
get back into making videos again which
means that I need a lead-up time to it
so I'm announcing my second exile it's
not entirely true again this is another
lie because it's not like there aren't
gonna be videos while I'm away but
everything that I just said it won't
start until the 14th 14th let me check
that 14th that's a Monday ok the 14th of
January is when everything else will
start back up what I just said which is
a rough plan but it's the absolute
certainty of the plan
I'm going to do so in general sense and
very specific sense I will start those
up on the 14th and then I will be
traveling back to LA in the few days and
I will lose my mind and not be able to
make videos that I explain are well
thought out and creative there will be
[ __ ] and also all the other videos that
I'm planning to make in the future will
be [ __ ] it's gonna be like markiplier
makes mistakes mark a lot of tries
cocaine
markiplier reacts to his own [ __ ] and
various other things like that that's
gonna be like the type of content that
you can expect but it'll be fun at least
for me as much as I always am hard of
myself about like you know I could work
hard or all I could do more stuff I like
I'm going into this year with a lot of
really cool ideas a lot of really
creative crazy ideas but uh I think it's
gonna be a great year and even if it's a
[ __ ] year well that means there's gonna
be a lot of memes about it and hey
that's gonna be funny
so can't wait for that so let's see if
this [ __ ] year is gonna be great or if
the great year is gonna be [ __ ] you
never know which is gonna get so
remember that quote me on that
write that on your yearbook so thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm gonna
get out of here because I got to get
that guy I gotta go to the New Year's
party or something unless I post this
tomorrow and then I gotta gonna pack I
guess anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you don't
don't the comments below
yeah whatever I'll talk to you guys soon
okay I'll be travelling I losing my mind
check me out on Twitter subscribe slap
that like button ring that bell ring
that Bell tell your friends I guess
there was some important things about
this so if there's people in the
community to watch my channel that
haven't seen this video yet make sure
they see it for update sake something
like that spread the word I think that's
generally gonna be instead of slapping
the like button smashing the SUBSCRIBE
tingling the Bell Run the balls of the
Bell tell your friends you know I don't
know if I have something important to
say and I guess this is moderately
important to say so c'est la vie see you
the next one bye bye